public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
brice hortefeux est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous à ce rendez-vous
de public sénat avec les échos avec
radio classique et avec l' agence
france-presse député européen vice
président de la région auvergne rhône
alpes vous êtes également j'ai vu dans
votre département
sur la liste des candidats aux
sénatoriales mais dans une position non
éligible un très bon c'est cela alors
trois grandes questions vous seront
posées au cours de cette émission
d'abord est-ce qu emmanuel macron fait
du sarkozy dans dans la forme dans le
style est également dans cette manière
de lancer beaucoup de réformes en même
temps jean francis pécresse vous le
demandera ensuite laurent wauquiez
candidat à la tête de l air est ce une
chance ou un risque pour la droite vous
le dirai à nadège puncak enfin les
sénatoriales devrait voir la droite
renforcer ses positions est ce que le
sénat va devenir plus que jamais demain
la base arrière de l'opposition michael
szames s vous le demandera mais d'abord
une toute première question d'actualité
[Musique]
elle s'impose c'est paris 2024 bien sûr
les jeux olympiques reviennent à paris
cent ans après ce que vous êtes gagner
comme les artisans de cette victoire par
un esprit festif brice hortefeux festif
c'était à peu prématuré heureux en tout
cas c'est la réalité
mais être heureux de ce signal vous
venez de le dire ça fait cent ans que
qu' on n'a pas accueilli les jeux
olympiques à paris donc c'est un signe
évidemment très très positif donc je
suis heureux mais heureux ça n'empêche
pas d'être lucide c'est à dire mal du
site c'est que on a été choisi mais il
n'y avait pas de concurrent donc ça
n'enlève rien au bonheur mais cela
encourage néanmoins à la lucidité à la
fin on enlève peut-être du mérite à vous
suivre se sont battus quand même je
pense âge avez vous demandé qu'il faut
t'il remercier françois hollande
emmanuel macron anne hidalgo peut-être
les trois n'ont même pas eu non pas deux
mais richie
anne hidalgo d'ailleurs même été plus
complète que vous puisqu'elle a indiqué
que le mérite en revenait à françois
hollande à nicolas sarkozy et au
président d'exercice donc c'est un
exercice et une démonstration de
consensualité qui est naturellement
sympathique mais je vous dis moi je suis
heureux ou incident plus lucides
notamment sur la facture parce que donc
là il ya un budget de 6 7 milliards
d'euros qui est prévu vous aimez déjà le
dépassement à combien cela je ne peux
pas l'estimé mais j'observe qu'un
certain nombre de ceux qui ont accueilli
les jeux ont eu des déboires
c'était le cas à londres c'était le cas
au brésil d'ailleurs c'était 15 52 kg
mettons tout en oeuvre pour que cela
tienne dans le l'enveloppent qui est
annoncé ce qui est vrai c'était un
argument qui peut pas être balayé d'un
revers de main c'est que la plupart des
infrastructures existent déjà on n'est
pas dans le cas de figure de ski c'est
par exemple déroulé au brésil où il ya
eu beaucoup de difficultés de retard et
de beaucoup de soupçons s'il est bon
c'est aussi une victoire pour toute la
france j'ai vu qu'il y aurait des matchs
de foot à lyon et st-etienne dans votre
région la région reprendrai gens
n'attendent région auvergne rhône-alpes
a donc aussi des manifestations qui sont
prévues et donc c'est d'ailleurs aussi
pour ça que d'autres
renaud muselier député européen et
président maintenant de la région paca
s'était rendu aussi bien sûr parce que
tu remarqueras il va en plus du foot
accueillir les épreuves de voile
pas exactement bravo donc à 2024 et ça
donne un peu d'optimisme qui sait bien
aussi un peu un climat consensuel dans
ce pays où on a la polémique facile
oui la consensualité je sais pas
forcément une fin en soi parce que dans
une démocratie il faut qu'il y ait un
débat et si on met la lieuse d'accord
sur tout évidemment ça tue un peu la
vivacité démocratie donc il faut aussi
qu'il y ait des divergences il faut
aussi qu'ils aient des différences et
finalement des là aussi pour y
contribuer justement c'est ce que je
vous propose de faire durant cette
émission apporter la contradiction
puisque tout de suite pour la suite de
l'épreuve de vérité nous accueillons
jean-francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
[Musique]
bonsoir en français sans soir michel
bonsoir brice hortefeux alors question
est ce que quand vous voyez agir faire
emmanuel macron quand vous le voyez aux
antilles aller au contact de manière
très directe avec les habitants les
sinistrés est ce que dans son style
en général ce que vous retrouver quelque
chose de nicolas sarkozy ce que j'ai
observé c'est que emmanuel macron avait
laissé dire ou dit lui-même que il avait
été impressionné par ce que faisait le
style méthode l'ambition de nicolas
sarkozy donc ça c'est un élément que
évidemment pour moi qui suis sarkozy et
qui n'entend pas changer d'ailleurs et
ce qui est une grande différence puisque
dans l'entourage de manuel macro et
macro lui même le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que tout le monde a changé il
était socialiste était avec françois
hollande il on bazarde et tout ça ils
ont relié ils ont changé d'étiquette n'a
pas inquiété mais pas nommée
ce sujet trois images il est certain que
je les ai bien à défaut dans mon coeur
je les ai bien dans ma mémoire
mon coeur non mémoire oui sinon il est
donc simplement donc simplement je je je
j'observe cela donc sur le style et
nomme pardon nicolas sarkozy est resté
fidèle toute sa vie à sa famille et donc
que c'est une différence avec emmanuel
macron deuxième élément si on va sur le
fond le rythme des réformes réelles sur
et n'aura pas le même et j'avais fait un
petit calcul sur les trois premiers mois
de mandat
si vous comparez ce que faisait nicolas
sarkozy qui a fait macron c'est un
élément factuel il y avait 30 %
d'initiatives de textes en plus à
l'époque de nicholas abbey donc c'est
pas du tout du tout le même rythme et
puis une troisième différence une fois
je n'ai pas mon réjouir ou elle
regrettait messieurs j elle constaté je
suis insurgés c'est qu'en termes de
popularité au bout de trois mois la
situation est absolument pas la même
et puisque même françois hollande
d'ailleurs été plus populaire qui est
venu almagro au bout 3 brad mandat et
nicolas sarkozy très très loin donc vous
devrez vont donc une forme de filiation
entre l'un et l'autre je ne vois pas
quand on prête à nicolas sarkozy ce mot
emmanuel macron c'est moi en mieux
c'était c'est une phrase je peux vous le
dire c'est une phrase qui a été colporté
mais jamais prononcé bon ce qui prouve
que le jeu n'a jamais jamais prononcé on
public en privé et ceux d'ailleurs qui
connaissent bien dit que la salle où j
imagine mal qui se haïssent est sûre
cette confidence la maison en tout cas
hors ce qui est vrai c'est que ça a été
que le porter mais je vous dis jamais
prononcé sur sur la méthode sur le fait
que quand même il ouvre un certain
nombre de chantiers en même temps il ya
eu la moralisation de la vie publique la
réforme du code du travail des réformes
de l'éducation qui arrive et puis des
réformes fiscales vous vous trouvez
qu'il n'en fait pas assez qu'il a qu'ils
l'ont fait moins que ce que vous aviez
fait vous et 2007 et on va vous
embrasser beaucoup de sujets ah oui si
on arrive au bout mais quand même ça
votre avis la réforme du travail je pars
je vais vous dire déjà ce qui me plaît
pas oui bon et après je peut constituer
un élément de réflexion intérêts 5 et
vous donne la loi sur moralisation
l'oeil public
on a tous j'allais dire tous
collectivement la le milieu politique
médiatique comme ça on a tous été la
baie parce qu'il y avait des mots de
moralisation de modernisation jeu plus
exactement derrière lesquels moi je
voulais une chose simple trop simple
c'est que cette loi conduira
inéluctablement à réserve et
l'engagement politique aux riches aux
retraités et fera fuir les meilleurs et
donc pour moi ce n'est pas un progrès
donc voilà typiquement un texte que si
j'avais été parlementaire nationale je
n'aurais jamais voté parce que je pense
que sur le fond c'est un texte aux
conséquences funestes
on voit bien l'idée rider peut-être
botte de progresser dans la transparence
démoralisé d'interdire les emplois
familiaux que ce n'est absolument pas le
sujet c'est vrai ça c'est des petites
même la poudre aux yeux c'est le sujet
c'est de savoir est ce que les personnes
travaillent ou travaillent pas et les
parlementaires et se sont pas des
multinationales et les parlementaires
sont des artistes et vexée observer
comment travailler les artisans il
travaille de cette manière là et parce
que pour avoir confiance et honnêtement
pour faire travailler aussi un petit peu
plus bas
donc mes jolies sur le fond et beaucoup
d'abus aussi aux de déshabiller là parce
qu'il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup des bleus
il ya beaucoup de pays européens où
beaucoup d'adjoints quel parlement terme
n'est pas passée par là mais je vous dis
droit pour moi la question c'est de
savoir si on travaille ou si on
travaille pas non mais c'est pas
tellement ça le sujet jeudi fut neige
vous donner un exemple très simple le
permettait on envisage c'est pas dans la
loi mais c'est ce qui est annoncé comme
devant être proposé en envisage
d'interdire d'exercice de trois mandats
plus de trois mandats consécutifs
on voit l'idée à vrai dire moi quand je
vais chez le dentiste et
en jouer chez un médecin et quand je
vais chez le garagiste me dit je me dis
pas cher quoi surtout pour qui est
pourvu qu'il ait très peu d'expérience
pourvu pourvu qu'ils très peu exploitée
c'est une vraiment j'attends ça de mes
atouts mais je vous donne un exemple
très simple parce que ces élèves de la
réalité moi je suis issue d'une région
vous avez évoqué l'auvergne obre est
très sensible et observant le fait que
par exemple il ya des médecins qui
s'installent et qui s'engage dans la vie
publique
parce que souvent les médecins médecin
généraliste vous le savez vous engage le
médecin il est à 28 ans il s'installe à
30 ans comme c'est souvent quand il est
sollicité pendant un conseil municipal à
32 ans il s'engage un peu plus il est
conseiller général conseiller régional
et coup de chance pour lui et ses idées
à 35 ans il est parlementaire
j'ai expliqué 4 50 ans il faut qu'ils se
remettent à jour qu'il faut qu'il se
refasse une clientèle naturellement s'il
ne fera pas donc c'est pénaliser
l'engagement je vous dis réservez la
conséquence pour la politique sera
l'engagement sera pour les riches des
retraités on va les fera fuir les
meilleurs sur le fond de ses réformes
est-ce que sur le logement sur
l'éducation sur le logement avec la
baisse des appels sur les réformes de
l'éducation sur la suppression de l'sf
sur le code du travail est ce que
emmanuel macron n'est pas juste en train
de faire tout ce que vous rêviez de
faire et que vous n'avez pas fait
écoutez j'ai pas rêvé de faire autant et
vouillé à droite on a mené pendant je
voulais vont pas arriver là nous n'avons
pas rêvé d'avoir un tendre a constaté
autant de cafouillages dans le projet
mais reconnaissez n'attendez
reconnaissez que sur les trois mois qui
se sont déroulés ça a été une
accumulation de quoi que d'erreur de 2,2
de départ contraint forcé comme on l'a
jamais attendez je vous dis pardon
quand on met à défendre qu'à la mini
sont obligés de partir dans les
premières semaines
oui mais on leur demande non pas depuis
ce que ça va dans le confort mais
attendu que sais je vous attends c'est
sur la forme et sur le fond est ce que
ces réformes est ce qu'elles vont dans
le bon sens ou pas c'est ma question g
vous répondre très précisément nom vous
dit rarement j'ai vu d'accumulation
autant d'accumulation de couacs et
d'erreurs bon sur les réformes
je vous ai répondu jean la loi sur la
moralisation mais moi je ne suis pas
dans l'opposition pour dire que tout est
à jeter alors avec l'eau du bain je vous
donne l exemple sur la réforme du code
du travail
c'est une première marche d'un premier
palier d'un escalier qui en comptera
beaucoup
vous comprenez ce que je veux dire c'est
une première marche oui bien sûr il ya
des éléments qui sont positifs mais il
ya des éléments qui sont très nettement
insuffisant vous savez bien vous êtes un
spécialiste de ces questions
l équilibre des accords de branche ou
entreprise n'existe pas ils sont ils
n'ont pas voulu aller assez loin
le gouvernement sur la négociation avec
un délégué du personnel
il fallait aller jusqu'à 300 salariés on
s'est limité à 50 ils ont calé mais vous
allez dire 50 etc c'est mieux que rien
les référents dans une entreprise
entreprises de 20 salariés
c'est un plus je vous dis souvent dit
très précisément jeudi
c'est la première marche sur un premier
palier d'années ce qu'indique alors
beaucoup aujourd'hui le premier ministre
a annoncé une nouvelle concertation
cette fois sur l'assurance chômage pour
une réforme à l'été 2010 8 on écoute
avec cette réforme
nous aurons certainement discuté avec
les partenaires sociaux de la
gouvernance de l'assurance chômage
sur ces deux volets nous allons engager
la concertation
et quand je dis nous c'est le président
de la république d'abord le premier
ministre ensuite la ministre du travail
avec l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales et patronales
vous avez entendu une voix philippe il
dit nous comment est ce que vous le
voyez dans son rôle de chef d'orchestre
que c'est l'image qui leur est utile
qu'il utilise est ce qu'il a trouvé sa
place à matignon
d'abord écouter expliquer pour un
gouvernant qu'il va avancer dans la
concertation je promets c'était bruit
fort naturellement et donc lui la raison
de dire qui va avancer dans la
concertation
le dialogue maintenant sur impasse du
poids ministre moi je suis gaulliste
donc je soutiens notre système
institutionnel actuel je suis pas je
peux pas dire que je sois épaté par le
rôle la présence du prévenu
j'avais dit un jour ce soir de boutade
qui n'était pas méchante
le premier ministre avait déjà un double
prénom il fallait maintenant qu'il se
fasse un nom mais tony voire non c'est
pas du tout ce que cela va du tout ce
que je dis vous me posez la question sur
son empreinte jeudi je vous ai répondu
je la question n'est pas d'ailleurs
temps des personnes je ne partage pas je
connais bien et loire fait depuis
longtemps je partage absolument pas la
démarche qui a été la sienne puisqu'il a
décidé avec deux autres membres du
gouvernement afin de rejoindre
précisément le président de la
république
ceci pouvait se comprendre dès lors
qu'ils obtenaient quelque chose mais je
n'ai pas compris ce qu'ils avaient
obtenu si ce n'est des responsabilités
et des fonctions ministérielles je suis
pas content j'ai pas compris ce qu'ils
avaient obtenu comme évolution puisqu'il
y avait défendu un programme qui était
différent notamment misé de l'économie
bruno le maire alors maladie paraît-il
en privé que il considère que madame
mâcon esprit libéral que lui oui gérald
darmanin nous avait habitués à des
pirouettes qui sont sans doute sa marque
mais je vous dis donc une fois moi je
respecte les personnes et les haies
dames et des individualités d'ailleurs
gira barman à quelqu'un que j'aime bien
vivre que je connais bien bruno le maire
que j'ai beaucoup côtoyé je dis
simplement je ne comprends pas et je ne
partage pas leur démarche puisqu'il on
s'était engagé dans la campagne
présidentielle et ils ont rejoint un
autre candidat qui est devenu président
la république mais sans obtenir quoi que
ce soit que nous avons une chose encore
leur place à l heure ah non je pense
qu'ils n'ont pas volé leur place ils
n'ont plus leur place et on peut
toujours nature en tout justifier enfin
voilà des personnes qui était membre des
républicains et qui ont fait campagne
contre les candidats aux initiatives des
républicains
c'est le mont avila la logique moral
moral s'impose assez vite
brice hortefeux vous avez été ministre
de l'intérieur qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la gestion par l'exécutif de
l'ouragan irene ce que vous partagez les
très vives critiques émises par eric
ciotti est-ce que vous parleriez de
défaillance de l'état le président de la
république a dit que viendrait sans
doute le temps d'une travail d'une
commission parlementaire ça je pense que
c'est bien qu'il ait dit ça ce qui est
vrai c'est que mais il ya des questions
qui se posent au minimum par exemple en
floride on a déplacé la population oui
mais c'est pas une il n'a mais on a
déplacé la bouille de saint martin et
saint barth céder sous l'administration
jusqu'en 2003 2004 mairie stration
préfectoral de la guadeloupe
donc c'est pas non plus à l'autre bout
de la terre j'observe que un pays qui
était concerné un territoire qui étaient
concernés par un cyclone identique le
même et à déplacer la population
j'observe qu'en matière de sécurité et
le sur l'île la partie hollandaise de
lille il y avait des positionnements de
militaire anticipée
donc la question mérite au minimum
d'être posé simplement moi ma
préoccupation c'est cette île je connais
saint-martin je ne connais pas saint
barthélemy mais je connais saint martin
je connais l'engagement du président de
la collectivité
ips
quand même c'est territoire qui 90%
j'évite du touriste directement ou
indirectement donc aussi je serai
attentif aux méthodes de reconstruction
de ce qui existe merci beaucoup sur
francis la suite de l'épreuve de vérité
tout de suite avec nadège pull jacques
de l' agence france-presse
l'épreuve de vérité avec l'efs
bonsoir nadège merci de nous rejoindre
notre question a l'impression au pied
alors c'est un risque ou une chance pour
les républicains
enfin enfin les questions at il enfin
une question facile bien sûr c'est une
chance bien sûr vous savez nous avons
perdu l'élection présidentielle avec un
débat qui a été totalement et toucher
pour toutes les raisons que vous savez
que hélas nous avons vécu on a perdu
dans une logique rituels les élections
législatives qui ont suivi
donc nous devons engager la phase de
reconstruction
ce qui est tout à fait possible c'est
pas quelque chose d'impossible moi je
suis très optimiste à vrai dire et cette
phase de reconstruction passe par une
élection et à cette élection
laurent wauquiez est candidat
franchement il incarne le renouvellement
la quarante deux ans qu'ils en profitent
ça ne durera pas mais en tout cas il a
42 ans et il a seulement trois ans
puisque le président un cursus plus
personnel qui est un cursus qui est très
impressionnant et en même temps il a une
expérience politique de deux à la fois
deux ministres est aujourd'hui de
président d'une région de 7 millions us
en mille habitants qui est une région
qui est aussi peuplé que la suisse aussi
vaste que l'irlande est avec sa
présidence de région sans l'apport des
voix socialistes
il aura fallu ig bien sûr de lui il a
gagné
en battant la gauche il n'a pas gagné
par des compromis avec la gauche l'a
gagné clairement ça leur en parle d'un
risque éventuel c'était contenue dans la
question quand même parce qu'il ya de
fortes divisions qui s'exprime autour de
sa personnalité et de ses options
politiques
oui il est normal que vous présentez ça
comme ça mais c'est un métier qui aucun
autre candidat et contre face à lui et
vous me diriez vraiment le prouve ce
pauvre parti est complètement atone ya
pas d'autres possibilités
non c'est pas une démocratie à la
chinoise chez nous et donc nous il y à
une élection il ya une élection il ya
donc plusieurs candidats vous appelez ça
des divisions mais c'est l'expression de
la 19 ans marqué par les divisions
bien sûr je vous laisse terminer les
moines mais moi je parle de celle ci des
visiteurs qui viennent
théologie un affrontement mais il y a
doucement des douches dans une formation
politique qui est démocratique dans une
démocratie ils huaient avoir la liberté
de choix il y a plusieurs candidats qui
se présenteront pour construire pour
apporter leur pierre à la construction
de ce qui doit être la grande famille de
droite qui soit j'y reviendrai sans
doute la fois fort populaire et sociale
et bien donc il ya plusieurs candidats
c'est rsa et s'il y en a des qui ont des
choses à dire surtout qu'ils viennent dé
dire qu'il vient de s'exprimer qu'ils
aient le courage de faire et puis ça
sera un mélange pas tout à fait
comprendre à ce que je crois que michel
ne vous parlez pas des divisions entre
les différents candidats à la présidence
de l air évidemment vous d'être pas dans
une démocratie chinoise et forcément il
y aura plusieurs candidats n'ont pas de
ça on parle de 1 valérie pécresse a
fondé son propre mouvement de xavier
bertrand une grosse personnalité grande
personnalité de votre parti accuse
monsieur wauquiez de courir après le fn
enfin iliad et constructif aller
constructif qui quand même
ou s'ils sont cuits ils sont plus chers
voulait constructif êtes d'accord qu'on
se consacre à la construction leur
carrière c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose
ça c'est vous qui le dites ces jeux je
sais pas bonjour à ils le font ils ont
d'autres options il voit les choses
différemment en tous les goûts même si
je sais les écouter non mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il ya déjà des
fissures à droite alors soit on voudrait
voir d'où est ce que monsieur wauquiez
est à même de colmater toutes ces
fissures de rassembler la droite et le
centre qui était la vocation première de
l'ump je vous laisse je comprends très
bien le voulais me conduire
moi j'avoue que je ne suivrai pas vous
dire les choses sont simples on a subi
un échec
on doit en tirer un certain nombre de
leçons et on doit donc se reconstruire
et se reconduire et donc il va y avoir
une élection
les adhérents de deux des républicains
choisiront le meilleur et nous serons et
moi je serai rassemblés derrière celui
qui aura été choisi quand même vous avez
un doute sur le résultat est ce qu'il
peut perdre cette élection il est archi
favori du temps oui oui ou non vous
savez le dit on s'était déjà appliqué à
l'élection présidentielle et c'est pas
exactement tout à fait comme ça que ça
s'est produit
donc donc moi je dis que partir mais il
ya des mots il ya vote naturellement il
doit y avoir et lessard précise
soutiennent laurent wauquiez vous
soutenez avaler sarkozy soutient évoquez
vous êtes sarkozyste dont vous soutenez
wauquiez s'était auto logique soit voilà
c'est une tautologie
non mais moi je suis je vous dis très
décontracté
je vous dit laurent wauquiez présente
c'est ce triple avantage à la fois
d'expérience de cursus de rajeunissement
qui est indispensable et deuxièmement je
pense sur le fond sur le fond que notre
devoir doit être de construire une
grande famille de la droite forte
populaire et sociale je tiens aux trois
je pense qu'il n'ya pas l'un sans les
autres et qu'est ce que ça veut dire une
droite forte et c'est une droite qui
fasse respecter l'autorité de l'état et
j'observe que ce gouvernement ne le fait
pas l'exemple de notre dame des landes
où il ya eu plus de 160 2 ou 60 363
décision de justice et un référendum le
poids ministre nous a annoncé la
concertation des commissions d théodule
et ainsi twitter qu'on n'en peut plus
tout cela
donc il faut avancer il faut que l'état
sache faire respecter ensuite une droite
qui soit une droite populaire qui soit
beaucoup plus offensive sur les
questions régaliennes que le fait le
gouvernement sur les questions
d'immigration c'est une question de
sécurité de justice je voudrais
simplement cet exemple les loi taubira
sont particulièrement néfastes vous
rappelle la mesure des mesures quelqu'un
qu'on donne jusqu'à 50 fait pas une
journée de soulever sous les verrous ce
qui est quand même assez surprenant et
qui laissait bailly un certain nombre de
nos observateurs étrangers notamment le
gouvernement dit absolument pas qu'on
revient là dessus que toi ça passe très
bien
donc il faut qu'on soit offensif sur les
sujets régaliens et enfin une droite
sociale parce que on voit bien ce qui se
passe avec ce gouvernement le
gouvernement précédent il avait fait des
classes moyennes sa cible
la payer chèrement que les classes
moyennes de gouvello quinquennat
hollande
et là on voit bien que les retraités
sont et seront la cible de son
quinquennat
et donc on nous devons à la fois défendu
classes moyennes protéger les retraités
et pardonnez moi de le dire aussi un
autre élément reconstruire enfin une
politique familiale je sais pas si on en
reparlera la politique familiale c'est
une politique qui ne des rares
politiques publiques une des deux
politiques publiques d'ailleurs avec la
sécurité routière pour lequel il y avait
aucune contestation possible ça marche
et le
quinquennat précédent à des môles
démonter cette politique familiale
on n'en mesure d'ailleurs les résultats
aujourd'hui puisque les chiffres qualité
ne sont pas bons c'était la classe ont
choisi minettes et j'ai entendu
aujourd'hui comme vous que dans le cadre
de la réforme de la taxe d'habitation il
y avait encore une évolution qui était
annoncé mais qu'en tout cas il y avait
une certitude c'est que d'après ce qui a
été annoncé par le gouvernement
et bien finalement les efforts seront
moins moins coûteux en quelque sorte
moins pénalisant pour un homme seul ou
une femme seul que pour une famille un
pardon c'est l'inversé qu'il faut faire
il faut au contraire toujours
systématiquement défendre la politique
familiale parce que c'est notre avenir
va vous voyez ça fait de grosse
différence avec ce qui fait aujourd'hui
et ça fait de grosse différence
peut-être aussi avec ce que proposent
d'autres eux voteraient le candidat
avant de vous faire écouter une grande
voix de la droite aujourd'hui qui fait
entendre une autre musique
je voulais vous reposer la question il
est donc favori en tout cas il est le
mien se suffit sans doute pas mais il
fallait bien alors une loi c'est
quelqu'un qui dit ni macro ni buisson et
c'est valérie pécresse un qui a lancé
son mouvement libre avec un point
d'exclamation pour moi il ya deux lignes
rouges
deux lignes rouges la première c'est la
porosité avec le front national alors
j'entends des gens temps vous avez pas
répondu j'entends ainsi si j'entends
j'entends que aujourd'hui beaucoup de
gages sont donnés sur cette absence de
porosité néanmoins moi je constate une
chose c'est que moi j'ai aucun leader du
front national qui dit qu'il aimerait
travailler avec moi alors quand l ai dit
ça évidemment avis monsieur wauquiez
puisque marion maréchal-le pen a dit
qu'elle aimerait bien rencontrer je
crois que c'est philippe aussi qu'ils
aimeraient prendre un café avec lui et
vous en pensez quoi
quand on dit qui courent après le front
national ou alors c'est dans votre nom
votre phrase est mal construites c'était
presque vous dissidents du front
national qui courent un produit mais
c'est pas le cas c'est pas le sujet et
écouter chacun se bat sur ces conditions
chabat chacun se bat sur ses idées
laurent wauquiez comme tout le monde et
colère comme moi même nous disons trop
sommes naturellement il n'est pas
question d'alliance avec le front
national
ça veut pas dire qu'on est au dessus
ouais pourquoi votre avis elle crée ce
mouvement dans le mouvement puisque
altics est au sein de l air qu est le
premier aliment non plus je ne suis pas
au dessus c'était assez naturellement
une progression de discussions avec les
les responsables du front national
laurent wauquiez s'est exprimé il a dit
clairement il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
c'est ce n'est pas de la revanche en
revanche les électeurs du front national
ne sont pas des sous citoyens et que et
bien sûr que notre objectif est que ces
deux dire aux électeurs du front
national comme aux électeurs déçus qui
ne manqueront pas de manuels macro comme
si certains électeurs aussi de la gauche
ces deux leur démontrer que nous sommes
porteurs d'un projet que ce projet peut
rassembler et que naturellement mais
c'est l'objectif c'est de vous êtes
porteur d'un projet vous nous expliquer
lequel qui peut rassembler rien
n'empêche on à monsieur estrosi par
exemple que vous connaissez bien on
avait été ministre mais pluie estrosi
aujourd'hui puis dit pis que pendre de
du mouvement des paires d'yeux de leurs
radicaliser et revenir les bienvenus
voilà à partir radicaliser madame
pécresse qui fonde son petit mouvement
mais je fasse son petit je sais pas il
sera peut-être grands d'ailleurs du
temps n'ayant petit 73e monsieur
bertrand m vous dites que vous êtes tous
vous avez un parti qui rassemble et qui
a un projet qui crée c'est bon mais
c'est l'objectif c'est l'objectif mais
encore une fois que ceux qui ont des
choses à dire il y avait quatre
candidats parlons nous dire s'il y en a
qui avaient des choses à dire essentiel
vraiment essentiel s'il y avait des
divergences profondes mais surtout que
chacun devant on est une grande famille
vivante démocratique ce qui franchement
qui n'hésite pas et la question peut
c'est pourquoi ni dont il pas qu'il est
la raison il doit venir d'un avis il
doit bien en demandera contre l'as v il
doit
en avoir une 1 pourquoi niveau si on a
des choses à dire si vraiment il ya
telle différence
franchement il y avait une opportunité
allez vous leur dites voilà la réalité
c'est que sur le fond il faut au delà
des mots des postures des slogans et
instituts et dire voilà sûreté le sujet
il ya il faut que nous en discutions
mais pour l'instant je n'ai pas entendu
moi j'ai pas entendu aucun d'eux
houssine des personnalités pour
certaines d'ailleurs que j'aime beaucoup
et que je respecte
edit ah bah voilà non pas du tout sur
l'immigration fou rire à tout vent j'ai
pas entendu dire pas d'autre nom n'est
total désaccord les retraités faut
laisser tomber
bon donc voyez encore une fois au delà
des postures des formules des slogans et
peut-être des arrière pensées
eh bien je crois que nous avons les
moyens de rebondir
nous avons un genou à terre et je suis
sûr que avec laurent wauquiez nous
pourrons nous relever merci beaucoup
m'avaient dernière partie de l'épreuve
de vérité avec mickaël zeze qui nous
rejoint maintenant
[Musique]
bonsoir michaël morin michel bouchard
hortefeux reçoit est ce que le sénat va
devenir la base arrière de l'opposition
en tout cas le sénat qui est une
institution qui est je pense
particulièrement utile l' équilibre de
notre vie démocratique je moi je suis au
parlement européen donc je regarde de
manière assez précise le fonctionnement
institutionnel des autres paix sur 28
pays aujourd'hui encore je compte même
si naturellement au royaume uni va
partir mais tu es 28 pays il y en a
treize dans lequel il y à du bicamérisme
est d'ailleurs sur les 13
il y en a de mémoire je crois 8 et pour
lequel il y à un système équivalent au
nôtre
la défense du bicamérisme c'est très
bien donc elles vont savoir cette norme
et julien donc premier mandat mais la
question première question pas c'est
vrai ce que c'est utile donc la réponse
vraiment d'observance système les
différents systèmes institutionnels
européens je pense la réponse est oui
c'est utile et vous savez c'était le
discours de bayeux du général de gaulle
en gros c'était l'assemblée exprime les
pulsions et le sénat les apaise quelque
sorte qui est une référence d'ailleurs
que le président larcher
inversement souvent rappelle souvent
deuxième élément oui l'enjeu de cette
élection sénatoriale qui suscite
beaucoup le monde va beaucoup d'intérêt
puisque record de candidats en 2004 il y
avait sept cent cinquante sept cent
soixante ans ni là on est à près de 2000
femmes 1990 les poussières c'est un
signal aussi à ses intérêts c'est ce que
voulait nous dire et donc le sénat ce
que je veux dire c'est que le résultat
des élections sénatoriales aura une
conséquence majeure pour équilibrer ce
qui risque d'être déséquilibré
qu'est ce qui reste des déséquilibres
mais appartient moment il n'y a pas la
majorité des trois cinquièmes
il ya un certain nombre de réformes
institutionnelles qui pourront ou pas
avoir lieu
et dans les réformes institutionnelles
qui sont envisagées eh bien je pense que
s'il n'y a pas les 3/5 ses réformes
institutionnelles il devra y renoncer
voilà donc pour vous le sentez l'âme
d'un jouet d'enjeux la droite l'enjeu
est grand en effet la majorité des trois
cinquièmes il y aura pas de récit et
s'il y a s'il peut y avoir des recours
possible érosion que ce soit de bonne
réforme
quand donc je dis donc l'enjeu tue à
résultats des élections c'est naturel
d'un enjeu majeur parce que 7,6 n'y a
pas de cette majorité des trois
cinquièmes ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas
de blanc seing qui est donné à la
nouvelle majorité au président de la
république donc c'est un enjeu majeur et
puis ensuite ya naturellement le
renouvellement du d adieu donc
l'opposition constructive voulue par
jarjat tall est par définition
l'opposition avait constructive
vous connaissez des oppositions que
c'est toujours contre ma peau du loup
non non moi j'ai vécu j'étais dès 6 ans
gouvernement j'avais des majorités
de gauche à des majorités des élus de
gauche qui ont voté un certain nombre
des réformes qu'on leur a proposées
notamment des réformes institutionnelles
d'ailleurs ça s'est passé de justesse
mais ça a été voté quand même et sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande il ya
des textes notamment en matière par
exemple de sécurité et qui ont été
votées par la droite
donc ça va les mots encore une fois je
comprends bien on est une langue le
français est une langue riche donc il ya
des postures et des alibis des choses
comme ça aura été une opposition qu'est
ce qu'elle doit faire l'opposition elle
doit critiquer quand c'est nécessaire
elle doit approuver quand c'est utile et
elle doit proposer c'est ça ou d'une
opposition sécurité je vais est très
très vite simplement je vais rester sur
les constructive là le groupe
constructif pourrait mettre également au
sénat est ce que ça peut faire exploser
le groupe ait l'air ici non je ne le
crois pas ça et je le dis mais papa avec
bonheur et fois mais moi j'ai passé j'ai
passé l'âge et des petites phrases et
des arrière pensées des petits calculs
de carrière et pour un certain nombre de
cas franchement ça m'inspire pas
beaucoup d'indulgence mais s'il y en a
qui sont sincèrement considère que ce
que fait le président de la république
ce que fait la majorité est formidable
c'est assez logique mais qu'ils aillent
au bout de leur logique qui les
rejoignent équité et l'annulaire mais
écoutez quand une fois je peux redire le
quotidien du féminisme une série de
personnes ont été investis soutenu est
finalement élu grâce à l'étiquette des
républicains et puis le lendemain ils
s'en vont franchement est ce qu'on ne
peut être épaté sur le pas sur le plan
n'aura donc je reçois épater les
sanctions prônée moi je pense qu'ils
doivent partir voilà bien repartir
clairement mais quand je rentre mais je
veux encore une fois je vends ta mais
les process du rugby actuel dans l'est
je vous le dis vraiment de très
profondément
cela serait respectable et morale les
deux voilà ils ont ils nous ont quittés
ils sont partis ils ont certains pour
certains étaient récompensés puisqu'ils
sont au gouvernement mais je pense que
ça serait plus morale et respectable
qu'ils en tirent toutes les toutes les
conclusions en parler de sécurité si
vous le voulez bien
ce projet de loi qui va arriver bientôt
à l'assemblée nationale
et des corrections qui ont été faites en
première lecture par le sénat ils ont
été complètement retoqué par le ministre
de l'intérieur notamment
des motions plutôt équilibré 3 jours de
pointage pour les assignés à résidence
ou encore les motifs de fermeture pour
pour les lieux de culte
est ce que vous trouvez le projet de loi
du gouvernement équilibré est-ce que
cela va dans le bon sens la réponse est
oui
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que le sénat
l'a voté
est ce que à mes yeux c'est suffisant la
réponse est non
je trouve c'est insuffisant
dans le cadre des précisément d
assignation à résidence
notamment il ya eu un dispositif qui
permettait à celui qui est assignée à
résidence d'aller se promener dans la
commune barça soit on est assigné à
résidence soit on ne l'est pas si on a
une dangerosité légèrement sur la
fermeture des lieux de culte vous l'avez
vous qu'il y avait sans doute une
faiblesse mais la première étape était
la bonne il sans doute il le fallait
plus loin et moi à titre personnel je
vous lis je pense qu'on ne fera pas
l'économie un jour de neige et de
possibilités accrues de rétention
administrative ça se fait un certain
nombre de cas psychiatriques
ça se fait aussi d'ailleurs dans le
cadre de migrations illégales
je pense que en matière de dangereuses
quand il y aura conviction de
dangerosité
il faudra passer à la rétention misrati
pourquoi je vous dis on avait déjà
entendu parler de cela lors de la
déchéance de nationalité mais on va
revivre en corner le même débat pour
tenir cette année mais parce que le le
faut bien comprendre l'évolution
incroyable de la dangerosité de la
menace qui pèse là où à la minute où
nous parlons il ya quatre ans auparavant
c'était pas du tout même chose
aujourd'hui comme vous savez le fichier
comporte 18 mille cinq cents personnes
et de geely à 2000 mineurs qui sont qui
sont concernés on avait sur le front en
syrie n'est
on avait sept mille en fin de day ch on
a sept mille européen
le tiers de français et un certain
nombre ont tenté de revenir même si
d'ailleurs la protection des frontières
européennes à considérable sur devait
aussi donc si vous en premier je vous
entends bien vous parlementaire
nationale vous voteriez ou dans ce texte
j'attendrai de voir la discussion je
serai à l'assemblée nationale
j'attendrai de voir les discours je
voudrais quand même noter que le sénat
vous avez loué la qualité du sonar
d'apaisement et a essayé de d'amoindrir
certes la portée de certaines mesures
défendues par le ministre dira que l'on
dit vous avez des mesures de droite
qu'il est ou en cheveux ici très
protecteur des libertés mais moi je vous
dis aujourd'hui la menace qui pèse sur
notre société c'est pas une menace qui
pèse sur nos libertés c'est la menace
terroriste et donc ça suffit pas ça ne
signifie pas qu'il faut pas les y est
naturellement pour les points je dis
simplement la menace principale c'est la
menace terroriste insee n'est pas la
menace sur dans libertés un mot sur
l'europe peut-être pour conclure une
question pour finir sur ce dossier
gérard collomb était là pour ministre de
l'intérieur vous l'avez pas vous mais
moi je ne
porte pas de jugement naturellement sur
les personnes et je ne doute pas de son
intention de bien faire même si je vous
dis il y a des différences dans ce
projet j'ai dit ne pas recommencer
il ya des mesures je pense qu'ils sont
mériterait soit d'être renforcée soit
d'être complété soit d'être ajouté les
travaux sont gerard et alors vous parler
un petit peu devant emmanuel macron
préconise des listes transnationales
pour les élections européennes est
quelque chose sur lequel nous serions
favorables
la ministre des affaires européennes est
venu rencontrer quelques parlementaires
européens et dont nous avons été
notamment 5,6 à la halle à rencontrer à
dialoguer avec elle adore ça c'était
d'ailleurs une bonne une bonne démarche
je dis simplement le listes
transnationales déjà c'est un argument à
lui seul cette sonorité pour tous les
eurosceptiques tuer est ce que l'europe
a besoin de s'éloigner elle a besoin de
proximité se rapprocher listes
transnationales par définition ça veut
dire qu'ils savent aller plus loin est
ce que l'idée c'est d'avoir des ddd des
députés étrangers européens
je respecte et ça c'est fait alors oui
mais bien sûr transnationales ça
renforce naturellement les populistes ce
mot-là fait est terrifiant on peut durer
des listes européennes d'un bep mais
c'est déjà le cas pardon de vous
rappeler daniel cohn bendit et été élu
en france nous avions à l'époque soutenu
un mot fameux coureur automobile
finlandais qui était arrive à thann elle
qui était tête de liste en région
pendant sa côte d'azur et tout ça et
vous avez eu un grand professeur de
droit français qui avait été huée en
italie qui s'appelait maurice duverger
pour les ceux qui ont fait du roi ça
existe et donc pourrait conditionner sa
capture et ils se réunissent dans
lesquelles il y aurait un peu de
slovaques un peu de la vérité ce qu'il
faut faire matière l'europe a besoin de
proximité
donc il faut essayer d'aller le plus
possible de rapprocher
l'élu européen des électeurs il faut
donc des circonscriptions régionales et
la ministre nous a indiqué que l'idée de
listes nationales étaient abandonnées et
que ça serait plutôt des liserés jaunes
sur cette partie là c'est bien sur
istres transnationales 6
totalement hostile est ce que vous serez
candidat à cette élection européenne
écoutez je n'en serais déjà je termine
je termine ce mandataire déjà pas si mal
on verra bien le moment en usine sur
vilaine c'est dans un an et demi les
nervis de votre pas l'envié moi j'ai
toujours envie bien sûr mais on verra
bien le jai beaucoup de choses qui me
passionnent dans la vie donc mais je
verrai bien le moment venu est ce que
vous voyez un nouveau vent d'optimisme
et de volontarisme souffler sur l'union
européenne après les discours du
président est en français et hier celui
vous avez ripper vous avez assisté
également celui jean claude juncker un
nouveau vent ya eu discours du président
de la république qu une partie qui était
bien sûr une deuxième partie qui a été
très mal reçue c'est sur les
travailleurs détachés pas tendre par les
vents falla revanche il ya eu un retour
de bâton assez violent à l'égard de ce
qu'ils avaient dit le président macron
et concernant discours du boyau d'une
guerre qui était effectivement je sais
pas tu es obligeant mais c'était porteur
il y avait une vision il avait des idées
enfin on peut pas dire qu'il ait validé
ce qu'ils avaient explique emmanuel
macron il a totalement pardon
l'expression 20 ans veut pas de
tristesse
en tout cas il n'a pas suivi le
président macron sur un certain nombre
de propositions sur le parlement de la
zone euro sur un certain nombre de
chômeurs au moins sur trois points
il a totalement écarté ce qui a dit
emmanuel compte mais ce qui est vrai
c'est que le président juncker a et
manière j y ai un peu inattendu et très
heureuse redonner de l'espoir
merci à vous présente au feu d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui
la semaine prochaine c'est françois
patriat sénateur la république en marche
l'ancien sénateur socialiste est très
proche du chef de l'état qui sera notre
invité dans le cadre notamment de nous
rendez vous sur les sénatoriales bonsoir
à tous à très vite
[Musique]
on